dernier coup de soleil c'est pas marrant
[Applaudissements]
notre dernier coup là
ah oui alors lequel justement interview
dernier coup
voilà
le jingle
pourtant j'ai regardé ben ouais je sais
mais bon
on va faire une interview au dernier
coup pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
très bien là tu peux bouger là
dernier coup de cœur dernier coup de
coeur Tourcoing
j'aime bien cette ville
moi c'est Jean-Pascal je trouve que
c'est un garçon qui a plein de talents
et d'émotions
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de poing dernier coup de
poing j'ai vu chez qui le Nil mettre un
coup de poing un mec là pendant un match
et j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire
moi à bouli dans les loges
un aspirateur 1500
ah si peut-être des filtres à café que
j'ai acheté hier j'ai claqué au moins
dans les 100 balles ouais 200 peut-être
en euros ouais ça fait ça à peu près
[Rires]
dernier coup de foudre
mais j'avais été chercher mon courrier
chez moi et en fait dans la cage
d'escalier donc je descends et je l'ai
croisé ma mère et on s'est regardé tout
ça tu vois
c'est un peu
ça s'est pas arrangé avec ta mère
ouais d'accord ok dernier coup de gueule
l'aspirateur après c'est engueuler quoi
de pub mais c'était avant l'aspirateur
regarde là-bas il y a une crêpe au
fromage qui t'appelle
[Rires]
j'ai appelé le mec pour qu'il fasse
marcher l'aspirateur d'accord
non moi c'est j'ai appelé mon père pour
lui expliquer par rapport à
dernier coup de roue je te demande pas
tu vois pas toi non non jamais jamais je
trouve que sans alcool la fête est plus
folle Thierry c'est ma devise
dernier coup de soleil c'est pas marrant
c'est bien de le dire c'est bien de le
dire
moi c'est quand je me lève le matin que
je tourne la tête et que je le vois
plus tard qu'est-ce qu'il est beau
qu'est-ce qu'il est mignon
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de blues
c'est là maintenant parce que je sais
qu'on n'ira jamais chez Fogiel quoi
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu